well I look really brown today excuse me
if I lit it weird people hey guys
mr. Ryan right here and Miss Sally
Lomonaco soon to be mrs. Ryan right
that's right guys we're engaged tell
them honey it's okay we've been in a
relationship for a long time now what
did you do before I got over here you
okay yeah okay it's gonna be great we're
gonna raise our quarter of an Asian baby
together it's gonna be awesome
speaking of Asians we saw a martial arts
movie that is not from Asian people call
the rate see how did that's called segue
all right a lot of people were telling
us we got to watch the movie the rate
right so we saw it and we loved it it
was hot topic there right loved it hot
topic all right so basically there's
this new trailer out the internet
trailer trailer number three and Sally
Lomonaco Veronica has yet to see the new
trailer any footage of the new one she's
missing out I'm not though cuz I'm
watching it with you and our viewers
yeah you're finally about to see
something it's exciting I don't know
what to expected because how can you
they I mean II read the first one no no
you can't so this one just has to be
different in some sort of fashion Sally
okay okay so it's are they gonna read
now I'm excited and real quick you guys
might have been seen Sally around a lot
lately I mean hey there's a pregnancy
disregard anything he says this is it
makes you eat we did a sonogram
okay whatever she's been you know busy
with school and stuff cuz that's what
she is a hard worker
yeah she'll be back more fully around
like me yeah yeah I'll be known and
she's gonna she's gonna make one hell of
an impact you'll see Matt she's it's
gonna blow your mind are you ready for
this I mean are you it's a minute and 15
seconds of Awesomeness you do this you
do this okay
Sonne picker trifles
it was selected to play at Sundance I
like the music
oh yes it's getting good reviews I would
you what it agrees that all right I'm
down I'm excited yeah he's back
ah
damn Oh fighting so rude there was a
girl see those girls
hey I'm so jacked oh we got insane
ah that looks so painful
oh that's gonna be one Elva car chase
now that's a [ __ ] trailer for you oh
my god you just make awesome imagery
Sayla yours your critics are saying
about it and it looks like it's gonna do
mm I'm excited those me like turn it
process everything I just want it
pageant hanging out with this person
every time she gets excited so is that
that exact emotion does a vet say [ __ ]
honey is that what's happening you crap
her pants this is what it looks like
what are you what are you presenting
ahold busy go I don't know where that
went
but yeah I know that movie does look
pretty bomb diggity it's exactly what I
wanted it to be I wanted it to me yeah I
wasn't disappointed with that at all
like how could you be way more than I
expected it's like you saw the raid and
what you--what do you want in a sequel
you want a more amped up version of that
yeah and it looks like they're giving
that to you there's gonna be a car chase
scene and I saw chick hello chicks think
it's hot chicks can kiss chicks can kick
ass too uh-huh I'm never gonna let that
go down god no please let it go gasps
miss Ellie's a reoccurring theme sup
yeah I mean what more can you really say
it's an action film it looks like it's
gonna deliver on the action it's gonna
be tough [ __ ] knotch right Sally yeah
[ __ ] not [ __ ] and the notch that's
what's happening and if you're new to
the channel watch sorry every single
time I try to do this new subscribe
button thing something goes wrong and I
just punch Sally in the arm are you ok
Sally you are you're really red right
now you're like a strawberry it was that
big oh you were laughing I thought you
were pissed off at me I was like ha this
is gonna look good for camera but oh god
I'm gonna get chewed up okay huh thank
God
I'll get you back later Sally scared is
like being one of the victims in
Paranormal Activity I know you demon oh
yeah subscribe to you subscribe to my
channel
oh yeah subscribe to her channel channel
called salamander Sally
subscribe to it you'll see videos of me
on there too you
be seeing him anymore though because I'm
going to kill him after this video but
please subscribe because I'll carry on
his legacy
of course so carry on our legacy whether
quarter of an Asian baby what no no no
no we're done with this conversation
goodbye